all right class now why do you think  shakespeare chose to make the curtains  blue maybe we can have a meaningful  discussion regarding our various  interpretations then come to a richer  understanding of the text take teach yes  maybe shakespeare just wanted the  curtains to be blue well authorial  intent isn't everything many of us  overlook the hey teach why do you keep  calling me teach you what your tyranny  of literary interpretation has ended  i'm having trouble understanding why  don't you have another look at that  shakespeare poem  you're right they're  they're just blue because they're blue  i'm smarter than you because i saw this  in a meme i guess i was proven wrong  by  lot by logic